hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from last year's video World
rapid Championship it is Magnus Carlson
versus and it is a quite a game to get
us started and into the mood for the new
world rapid championship and the world
with Championship uh but the question
remains as Magnus uh after losing his
game to Hans in the classical time
format he has declined to play hunts in
any time format whenever he was faced
against him uh albeit online but the
question is what happens if Magnus is
let's say he's doing really well he's
leading the the rapid section he he's in
first place currently and then he has to
play against Hans will he again just
decline to play will he give up a full
point or will he actually play this time
uh there's no way we can know he did fly
all the way to Kazakhstan at uh to play
the for for the world rap and Bliss
Championship so he definitely wants to
win it but I mean will he play against
him that we will have to see so I
thought to get us in the mood a very
nice game between Magnus and alireza
from last years at World rapid
Championship that was won by another
because of let's check it out and yes
today in a few hours we will be having
this year's Christmas Arena it's
sponsored by elron the the Multiverse uh
X as it's being called now uh so do
check it out it will be the first link
in the description below many strong
players have already enrolled over 2 000
players and you guys are welcome to join
in and try to take away a few points
from uh from them uh or all the points
all depends on how how good you are uh
so yeah uh that being said let's check
it out and uh later on uh we're going to
live stream the event it starts at 6 p.m
Central European Time uh so I hope you
guys can make it so Magnus with the
white pieces here opens with E4 alireza
goes for the Carl Khan he plays C6 with
d for D5 and now Magnus advances the
pawn the advanced variation of the Karo
Khan with Bishop to F5 and now Pawn the
C4 not going for anything crazy Ponte 6
we have knighted the C3 and here alireza
goes for Knight to E7 we have H3 and now
Knights the D7 already an incredibly
rare setup only a handful of games uh
Knight to F3 and now Bishop to G6 and
already as of move 7 we have a
completely new game so Magnus continues
with B3 he wants to Finca to his dark
Square Bishop we have Knight to F5 and
now Bishop to E2 this Knight is now a
monster and if Magnus wants to kick it
away he will have to at some point
Advance the pawn to G4 or try something
else but more likely is that alireza
will bring his Knight to H4 to try and
trade it off for magnus's Knight on F3
so Bishop to B4 and now Bishop to B2 we
have castles uh and both players Castle
so castles castles F6 now alireza wants
to break up a magnus's strong Center and
pawn to A3 chases away the bishop Bishop
to A5 and now C capture C captures and E
captures on F6 now you could capture
with the Knight but alireza has
different plans for this night at some
point the night will come to f8 to help
out with the defense of the backwards uh
E6 Pawn so Queen captures an F6 instead
Rook to C1 by Magnus and now Knight to
H4 going for a trade of Knight so he can
uh remove some of the Defenders away
from the white king Knight captures
Queen captures and now Pawn to B4 and
alireza doesn't bring the bishop to B6
rather he brings it all the way to d8 uh
for some reason uh but I have no idea
what that reason is maybe he wanted to
bring it to E7 and then to D6 maybe
that's the idea uh but okay Magnus goes
best of the G4 puts pressure on the E6
pawn and now Bishop to F5 now if Magnus
wants to trade all it is that moves the
roof from f8 and then the Knight can
finally come to f8 with Bishop captures
Rook captures and queen to E2 now Magnus
goes after the E6 spawn Knight to f8 uh
defending the E6 pawn and now Knight to
D1 remember during the night the E3 to
harass The Rook on F5 and here Bishop to
B6 now alireza brings the bishop to B6
you could also consider some Rook G5
moves H5 to start an attack but he first
wants to improve the position of his
bishop and now Knight the E3 attacks The
Rook Rook to G5 and now Pawn to F4 uh
chasing away the rook and here alireza
should play Rook to G6 but he plays Rook
to G3 and this really allows the Magnus
to kick start uh his his part of the
game so feel free to pause the video and
try to figure out what is wrong with
Rook to G3 uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
foreign
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh always thinking
about using every piece and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is King the H2 that's the move Magnus
played and now uh it's not easy for
alireza to find the move because Queen
E1 and queen F2 will trap The Rook The
Rook will not be able to move as the
queen on H4 will be undefended so
alireza brings it to G6 now which sort
of loses him the tempo and now Magnus
should continue busting open the
position with F5 but he goes for a
different plan Knight G4 he wants to
bring the Knight to E5 where it will be
a monster Knight Queen back to d8 and
now Pawn to a for just grabbing more
space on the queen side with Bishop to
C7 now going for the King on H2 and B5
with Bishop to D6 alireza doesn't want
the bishop and C7 to remain a Target and
now Rook the C3 helping out with the
defense of the third rank but also just
preparing to double up on the C file so
while it is a counter is that he plays
Rook to C8 Rook captures Queen captures
and now Knight E5 and this is now a
truly a monster Knight attacking The
Rook Rook to F6 and not Rook the C1
attacking alirez's queen queen to d8 and
now Pawn to G3 and here uh this Knight
is obviously much much stronger than
this bishop but alireza prefers to keep
the tension he doesn't want to eliminate
the Knight he continues to Rook to F5 uh
we have Queen to D3 now and pawn to G5
also capturing and then Pawn to G5 is is
an option but he goes for G5 right away
but now Magnus goes for Knight to G4 and
here you can see how maybe capturing the
Knight was the way to go now it is it
has to worry about Knight H6 check which
will win the Rook so King to G7 and now
Knight to E3 again forces the Rogue back
Rook to F7 and now Pawn to F5
threatening to completely destroy
Black's uh position Queen to D7 adding
another Defender Here and Now Rook to F1
uh putting more pressure on the f file
H7 6 and now King to G2 they are getting
the king away from this diagonal King to
G8 and now again Magnus goes for it
Knights the G4 this King the G8 move
really wasn't the way to go uh but it's
rapid so Knights the G4 again threatens
a nice Fork here so King back to G7
already is a force to bring the king
back and now F6 with check King h8
Knight captures on H6 so Magnus wins a
very valuable Pawn Rook to H7 and now
Knight back to G4 we have Queen to E8
hoping to get some maybe Queen H5 Queen
H3 action in uh but just the bishop to
A3 attacking the bishop on D6 and uh
interestingly even if you go for this
you could still just capture the bishop
you don't really care about this even if
you lose the Knight here if King G1
Queen captures and G4 F7 and there's no
defense against the bishop P5 this will
be made in one and if you want to avoid
being mated in one you will have to
suffer severe material loss so after
Bishop to A3 alireza has the character
we have Queen captures on A3 and now
Queen to C8 hoping to get some activity
with the queen but just Rook the C1 of
course Magnus will not allow this queen
to E8 and now Knight the E5 and now you
can see that the knife controls very
important squares here F7 will be an
option the queen cannot move because the
Knight here would hang so very very uh
tough position for alireza King the G8
is played but now Queen to F3 preparing
uh Pawn to F7 so Queen to d8 and now we
have Rook to F1 bringing even more fire
Firepower to the f file King to h8 and
now Queen to E3 just going after the G5
Pawn uh Queen to C8 hoping to get some
counter play here but Magnus doesn't
rush anything just on Rook to F2 we have
Pawn to G4 oh it is a has to try
something active H4 and now Rook to H5
and here comes Knight to F7 check King
to G8 and Knight to G5 anyway was in
this position animal 53 that alireza
firuja resigned in the game as there is
nothing more to be done here to give you
an example uh of maybe what you could
play but uh there are really nothing you
know like F7 and queen E5 just to get
the job done whatever you play even if
you try something like preemptive King 8
again Queen E5 threatens F7 mate and uh
well if Knight G6 of course then just
Knight F7 check will pick up the rook
and you okay it's not even uh an
exchange because this also wins the
night so maybe King yet now even F7
checking f8 they're gonna play Queen to
GH checking E7 uh and you can capture
Black's Queen so nothing really works
here and of course alireza had to resign
but you can see that both of them had
chances it was uh uh you know it could
have gone either way but in the end the
Magnus came on top alireza I played some
a couple of weird moves with the King
and that was enough for Magnus to again
that one tempo that he needed to really
really start his attack uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
like I said if you if you want to join
the tournament and have a chance of
facing some very strong players it will
be the first link in the description
below you have to have at least 50 rated
games played in order to participate
sort of a way to eliminate uh people
using Bots and you know uh new accounts
that are made specifically for cheating
it's not impossible I mean you you can
play Just 50 rated games but maybe it
will discourage most of them so yeah I
really hope you guys enjoyed it I really
hope you guys can make it to the to the
live stream into the tournament uh who
knows maybe you'll be the Grand Master
today maybe not but if you don't play a
chances are you you will not be the
Grand Master today uh so yeah once again
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Daniel Stone David grosskin
Paris Scott melis and the Jack Schroeder
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day